après des années et des années de débats
il y aura finalement retour de cours
d'éducation sexuelle cet automne mais
seulement dans une quinzaine d'écoles la
province d'un projet pilote et anne
louise despatie va vous expliquer dans
une seconde que déjà on ne s'entend pas
exactement sur comment on va donner ce
cours là voici le reportage
celle qu'on parle de la mort parce qu'il
savait pas vous fêtez votre connaissance
au niveau des partis c'est sexologue
préparent à leur façon leur rentrée à
l'école depuis des années l'organisme
l'anonyme donne 13 ateliers différents
dans des écoles secondaires tous les
jours ces spécialistes mesure l'impact
de la disparition des cours d'éducation
sexuelle dans les écoles du québec au
milieu des années 2000 pour une
reconnaissance au niveau du consentement
les gens pensent un silence oui elle
semble bien révolue l'époque où la
sexualité faisait rougir en classe et
d'élégance
les jeunes québécois font plus tôt face
maintenant à une augmentation des
infections transmises sexuellement et
amine épidémie de faussetés véhiculées
sur le web on se rencontre on transmet
alors que les jeunes tombent dans leurs
champs
le retour de l'éducation sexuelle était
demandé par bien des parents des
enseignants et des intervenants santé
publique
l'ontario a modernisé son programme
malgré la protestation de plusieurs
parents au québec
cela prend d'abord la forme d'un projet
pilote dans 15 écoles primaires et
secondaires dès cet automne mais on ne
sait pas encore lesquels et les
enseignants sont dans l'inconnu on
absolument aucune information quant je
voudrais tout l'environnement mais aussi
au niveau du contenu on est inquiet 5 à
15 heures qu'on emballe curriculum ça ça
veut dire qu est-ce qu on passe on fait
moins de français ont fait moins de
mathématiques
les ministres françois blais dit avoir
consultée je comprends que la formule
qui étaient propres proposée par les
représentants des syndicats n'a pas été
retenue pour des raisons pédagogiques
essentiellement mais quand même on
l'informé je pense qu'il tient la route
et qu'on devrait pouvoir évaluer la dans
les prochaines années
la directrice de l'anonyme n'a pas été
consulté mais elle a proposé son aide au
ministre j'aimerais connaître le contenu
j'aimerais peut-être contribué housse
avec l'équipe de professionnels qu'on a
ici on peut devenir un partenaire
intéressant pour le ministre aussi en
attendant la fin de ce projet pilote
les organismes comme l'anonyme ne
peuvent être présents dans toutes les
écoles qui cherche à combler le vide des
dernières années ici anne louise
despatie radio canada montréal